what's your right stuff
the world is my oyster and i shall suck
the juice out of it
where's my horse i forgot how to play
this game yeah i know that wasn't
between a new game actually
shall i explore this castle
[Laughter]
isn't that from resident evil 4
below tombstones cannot be used now
because it looks like a
oh
an elden ring i love that they look like
penguins when you're standing up it's
cute
four told foul oh yeah we found that
cookbook too
yeah
i don't you call it hirona
oh well we found recipes
oh maybe jacob doesn't want oh that's
not good
all right
oh crinkle the fire
oh are you slow rolling i think so cause
you're all burned up i died of me i'm
cold now yeah
should we close the window
can i have a coke
yeah we do have a big bag of them right
here oh yeah
i don't want to drink all your mexican
cokes i wanted six more
whoa
all right so we got a bit of a there's
still chilly too
all right let's see
oh
you got this jacob oh my god that's a
lot of a lot of barricades
anytime
[Music]
you can't really just like ride past a
lot of the yeah enemies
i mean you can do that in dark souls too
yeah
oh
the pork killer
is close
this way i don't like it
[Music]
and you can lock onto their legs
oh grundle
oh look at this big nasty sack
oh god
oh
[ __ ] it might it might scale based on
the area yeah
we thought that one earlier on well
there's also the network tests where
we're way leveled up yeah
okay i got to find a way into the castle
because port hall's closed
there wasn't a lever
uh probably not that would make sense
security wise look from here there's
that i bet you up in the tower
the hallway through that tower or also
the cliff along the side too oh yeah
yeah it goes all it looks like it goes
all the way along all right we have our
heading
oh and the
uh
[ __ ] grace is guiding us here
yes there's something here
you got this chicken
hey
oh
just no one reacts
at all
she's very i'm leaning very anxious
about
us right now i think oh poor girl
it looked like there was an item up in
the tower yeah
here let's do this
oh [ __ ]
horse can't jump that up he's just
jumping and slamming his horse into the
rocks i think i just shot his friends
oh it looks like you have to go into
that place from above like there's not a
ladder
oh [ __ ]
i went for it
oh i wonder
if you
if you double jump and then click the
left stick oh you're
fat rolling how are we suddenly fat
rolling
oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i brought you jump at shield yeah i
should have taken in my surroundings
okay look at his neck
okay yeah i wonder what is causing us to
fat roll do we put anything on like
gloves on or something
i don't think so
is it oh was it the towel oh it was the
talisman 0.7 and we don't even need it
yeah let's take that oh it says x right
yeah
medium load okay
not medium loads are not something i'm
familiar with nope only max loads yeah
heavy loads heavy thick [ __ ]
all right
okay
so i wonder if i'll try to get up to the
top again and get around the cliff side
yeah i think that'll do
i 100 forgot that we were recording
offices
how much fun we're having i know we just
want to play elden ring dang it
this is what our fifth
hour uh when did we start well we've
done one
cycle and then i started again so yeah
we've recorded four oh my god
he's dang ballistas
yep
they keep hitting each other
yeah where's big boy he's up there
here it comes
who wakes me from my slumber
that's a close one
[Music]
coming down are you
ah you're good
hello sir
nice
it's nice guys
can you launch yourself
like get in the trebuchet yeah throw
myself across the map
oh yeah this looks like the way uh-huh
ah
cave creature [ __ ] hell
those are freaky bats yeah
that was a little awkward uh positioning
yeah
okay
get your pass
dude it's like the gargoyles in uh
cainhurst castle are the most
like the lamest yeah
you hit them once and they fall on their
back and just squirm they're also like
just derpy yeah
all right aha a new foe
i missed i mean i laughed but one of
these is going to knock me off
all right get back up here
what are you doing you can write it
oh
clicking off like an avatar
all right oh come on
stop it
get down
dude little [ __ ] [ __ ] annoying yeah
i guess jump you could
all right let me see if i can get up
here without a big deal more
get more bats
oh hello look at that skybox
trap ahead
whoa
that doesn't look good at all
i see enemies and bats
and there's a dude with like a cloak
standing under that tree yeah oh it's
also a pit too
must have your horse
all right yeah
wonder if that's the trap it's just
somebody fell in the hole
i think motherfucker's gonna come from
everywhere
nice jacob
did they even notice you i don't think
so was it bats there's like a guy
there's a guy with like a what's wrong
with his arms i'm not sure
it doesn't look good there's a little
beetle boy i say i bet you there's like
a grace inside or something yeah let's
do that just in case we came all this
way
hello
who's there
ah nobody
does not open [ __ ] oh try uh dark souls
2 try hitting it
do work or no no no don't sneak like
aggro him
hello
hit it hit it again hit it again
are they not going to open it
nah
so no dark souls 2. kill them
kill the bitty woods
good job
oh there's a ladder to climb though oh
perfect
somebody uh coming down it oh there
might have been somebody that i accurate
on the other side
oh
you're gonna come get me eh
nice
i think it is going out into that
graveyard is bad news yeah
i think you're right
let's just
find a grace or something over here
because we could all risk it yeah
cool moves criminals just have like a
big robe on i said okay whatever
oh we're getting up on the roof
yeah please be grace i want some grace
oh no
redmayne castle eddie redmayne
my great life
nice
we have their shield yes we do
it's a good shield too
come on grace
i know i need some grace
what's up inside the castle or sorry
down inside the castle looks like
there's some courtyards and stuff
there's a guy's
door oh boy
seems like we should have found a
something here some sort of shortcut and
still sneak out
maybe from this roof area we can get to
open the port police yeah
how do you is it port cullis port
coliseum
port colors port
coast
just lower your colors
all right fire sword poor khalis
[Music]
are you the only one do you have any
friends
oh you know the other thing
that treasure map we bought or the
treasure oh yeah
because i think that's one of the
potions we had in the network test that
like
boosted your strength and healed you
oh whoa
ardorius
it is the flips
[ __ ] oh
no holy [ __ ] did you get all ashy
because you burned to death i think so
yeah he
crunched my body away
wow
all right so castle's got some toughies
in it yeah and there was no
nothing marika whatever yeah
holy smokes should i go back up there
your call brother
or we can explore more i gotta go find
that treasure yeah what was the item
again
the things we were looking at the maps
yeah ancient dragon
cookbook
no no press x
dragon wound grease
so
do we just have that now i guess
i guess okay i keep going right
there it is
oh
uh
what are all those things
little screenshots
uh oh they're just the grace locations
like delicious
yeah i don't know oh no it's like
tutorial
yeah
oh red maid painting yeah
i found that oh no
were you there you might right there it
was it was in the haunted place
the third church of america north of the
mistwood have we seen that yet
where
i just want to
see go back real quick what's the
problem go back there was more
information
oh
try going left and sit right
boom
cross the highway bridge and follow the
animal trail more oh yeah i read that
part
oh i didn't hear you say it oh no i
didn't say it out loud
uh so there's a bridge
oh
bridge
that's got to be the bridge yeah wait
where's the church of america
that's the question
it's a bridge
the only bridge i can think of well that
looks like a bridge too actually
and we checked the bridge
we might have not found the church with
mario coaster it's not on the map it
could be anywhere
red main castle i want to take one more
go at the couch go for it
all you bugaboo
tally who
these castle enemies seem pretty tough
likes to live on the edge yeah oh god
here comes someone so how are they
reloading them so fast yeah for real
there's like one guy working that
trebuchet
[ __ ]
whoa cool you see that cool action shot
yeah that was dope
oh badass
i thought i'm gonna heal just in case
i just feel oh i got my horse still oh
my god
okay move this way in down here
through this like bottom area
there's definitely there are people
already aggroed on you yeah just not
this guy on the other side of the tree
oh okay
i think there's an archer that was
shooting at me
just chilling out under a tree yeah
let's have a little rest
hey
i can't do that
yeah that's kind of a bummer with
riposte once you hit him it like takes
them out of the
oh we got a trebuchet operator here
does the work of a hundred men
fire damn that did a lot of damage yeah
we might want to put some points into
health yeah it has been going on we're
glass cannon right now yeah well more
like a glass hammer yeah
oh [ __ ]
nice look at those high frames that's
safety from this guy
oh [ __ ] okay oh these guys are bad news
just gonna do this little dance
there's a ladder on the back side of
that oh go
oh what was in that tent oh i must know
he just [ __ ] off
maybe hey no ladder oh smithing stones
though
i need a heel
oh yeah
oh
jacob
i'm just like on a desperate item
collecting spray now
i don't think there's any ladder i bet
you there's something in that tent
there's a platform above it yeah so i
think you have to go up there and then
drop down excuse me
oh yeah there's definitely something in
there there's nothing
jack [ __ ]
what about over here
maybe off the cliff no not but death
[ __ ]
okay let's just keep going around
i've got one flask left
it's give me a little boost on my way
little
kick kick with the spurs yeah or
something however cowboys say it yeah
all right this is uh not the best
do you have a horse
you're right
got so caught up in the combat
oh there they go blow each other up
again
so yeah see there's that platform oh
yeah let's jump on the back
oh
hey what
be much you know
what oh that's why there's the ladder ah
there's like some way that you can
open the top
yeah
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] hey
you blowing smoke up for us quiet over
there
is there anyone even in here
i don't think so they might have gone
down
damn it maybe what about on the back
right corner
that's where the last chest was
nothing okay
is there's oh i guess there's the item
down yeah that's all we got
and then you fall to your death yeah
it might be oh oh
okay let's just climb back up real quick
and
[Laughter]
oh you've tripped
all right now let's get mine look at
swords floating
or no wait oh this is a sphere here it's
a sphere it's a
staff with a broadsword on the end of it
this better have been worth it
i mean that's actually we need those
we could upgrade
so many times yeah because we've gotten
a few yeah
all right i don't know if i can get back
out of there again all right back down
here actually wait you can double
jumpers too yeah
or do a single jump and then double jump
on ground
nice how candy
what the [ __ ] so it does it does uh
account okay
it's not that simple like
does look really goofy before you try
the castle again i think you should go
to the anvil yeah i think i'm going to
leave the castle before for now
just go get some upgrades in
[Music]
here yeah yeah church of hello
okay
where's our anvil friend hello santa i
need to use some uh he's straight up
santa yeah i need to use some uh
stiffness yeah
probably
let's see how much it costs actually
oh
right because you die 636
wait a minute i only have two smithing
stones still
what
oh those might be special smithing's
they might be a higher tier
or something because i remember they all
had different names
what
let me look at my inventory
yeah go to your shirts page just this
little yeah oh
yeah so we only have a couple wait
yeah these oh
oh it's smithing stone six i thought it
was six smithing stuff that's what i
thought too
a reinforced armament's about so i don't
have what i need
[ __ ] ass [ __ ]
you wanna go find that flask for that
bridge oh jacob what
make it nighttime and then go to that
bridge which bridge the one on the map
okay
let's
pass time
until nightfall
hello
nice john's telling me to go to a bridge
at night so what's happened
uh i tried to take castle red vein and
failed spectacularly
it went real well so we're back to
margaret i could i am you want to
explore alana yeah
come on along
whatever you want john wants to explore
and by we i mean john
so that bridge yeah that bridge there
huh what is that giant telescope that's
a great question
oh did you mark it i marked it i set a
beacon
oh excuse me dear
excuse me
oh excuse me
there it is
all right
to the bridge
night
cold out at
it's cold we discovered that if you jump
off a cliff oh [ __ ] the double jump
walks or not no wow
it uh you do the double jump by the
ground it still kills you
huge bummer but it makes sense because
that's like cheating yeah that's video
game jumps
um
right just mash why while you're writing
oops
that's why it's just it looks so silly
all the trees are so pretty
this feels like starting area energy
right like this is where you're supposed
to be open field
yeah we're in the we're in the first
down
i mean it's a good
good method i guess there he is
whoa he only appears at night
oh
oh [ __ ] oh god he's got friends i'm from
oh is he killing them too
he's like
okay
nice cavalry we've been a while since
we've seen a boss
it is very hard to get the hits in
okay
okay
i didn't do anything to him
whoa he jumped over yeah yeah that's
cool
nice
it looks like it's so weird that you
keep missing
you can't do that
all right this is gonna be
a just want to get these guys out of the
way
how did you know about him have you seen
him in videos yeah
oh
yeah
all right
i want to hit him
no he wants to hit me careful horse oh
did he just fall oh my god did he fall
i think he may have
but he's probably still alive down there
where is he leave me alone
oh he popped back up do you see that no
i didn't
oh you can hurt his horse too oh he
really hits me hard dude i i think you
should ditch the heart you think so yeah
it's so hard
and there are more dudes over there
he keeps his
distance oh
oh he's fine
you just pop back yeah he
look at his horse he's like in a sh
under a drake
maybe he does kind of the same thing
yeah he seems slow
yeah he also rams with the horse too
it's like the two princes
you think they're in love
you look so cool yeah
you're doing good actually better
[Music]
yeah otherwise do it great i do kind of
want to come back if i fail this yeah
oh good thinking
always forgetting the wolves out of
there they don't let you know
the wolves are grayed out you still have
fb
it might be a boss fight i don't know
what a disabled wolfster when it's
raining i don't know no walls when it's
right i don't want to get wet
you got this dude
if not this then i think you could be
the tree center
right like
ah damn it's those little little bumps
oh my god what is coming through here i
got distracted for a second i think i
might have seen that during though
yeah yeah the plate says it's in the
trailer
horse is almost dead
oh you're right
and then his entire move set's going to
change
yeah it's going to be great we're ready
for it so much help do you not have any
items
i don't think we do you have a license
like you have
nice
yes
okay so when he falls off his horse
you can get that cheap
special attack i need to make it time
again you can do it we could do that we
could do that
look you can do it still you've
eventually been like never mind
i think every episode it's a different
name all right
do i have pants
i don't i'm not going to check
are you going to upload them all at the
same time or i'm not sure yet
i'm not sure like i will
because it's like maybe i should because
it's a pre-release and people want to
see the footage
maybe every hour for the first day yeah
good
i mean people can't watch it faster than
an hour
unless they turn up the playback speed
or something but then i would be
uploading probably like all of it in one
day
oh yeah
oh yeah
it doesn't really matter yeah your bats
those bats [ __ ] work yeah they're
they're the irritating enemy yeah
the runes
i do want to rob that caravan
you fall asleep i just [ __ ] ran with
the dog she's making me run so i was
like i think maybe it's energy jacob
killed
sorry
the ads they're ads get them first
that's not a bad idea kill the ads
yeah that was the plan
i play video games
anyone else i think that was it those
were there were some more but i guess
they walked away yeah
stupid blue tick
so did you decide that it's better to do
without standing on the mountain yeah
that was like i could even hit him yeah
it's hard to orientate and you can't
like roll dodge
yeah it's hard to get i-frames i feel
like the mount is really good for
smaller enemies
that dragon move where his dragon is
like see there's guys over there oh yeah
i'll stay up keep it in the middle of
the bridge
i don't trust him so funny does he need
to do that
yeah he swings over his head and he
doesn't just overestimate
hard to be on a horse
it is
okay i can hit him too
yeah yeah
seems like it just way less
[Music]
we're good we're good
oh
yeah it did exactly the same as
i was gonna do that
little side munch that's hard to
see yeah
yeah there's a lot of attacks that are
just so quick though
next black idiot
all right turn around
yes that distance just a little bit of
distance sometimes
bad timing oh oh oh my god i thought you
were dead yeah
i might just take a second to drink
another blast yeah
oh you [ __ ]
oh
get over here do you think that you
maybe get better as you get more
stressed like as your costs go down you
improve because yeah you're safer yeah
yeah sometimes caution you don't want to
be too cautious though because then
you're just wasting a bunch of time yeah
you also i think have those lightning
bombs oh yeah yeah yeah
are they still equipped yeah oh god the
caravan's coming
you're gonna hurry this along
no the caravan will leave you alone
i'm so curious about what's in it
treasure beyond count yeah it's like the
it's the
next to the camp we saw
parked caravans
yeah they had treasure chests yeah
there's just a chest in the back oh yeah
we do
oh [ __ ] oh
oh bad luck
all right this is gonna be my my quest
for sour
you got this jacob
if you use a blue ciphering you'll make
yourself open to someone to arrest you
from other worlds
sounds
i mean she's finally asleep that's what
she needed
more exercises it happened
no more yelling
sorry i'm just doing some business
emails oh
come on through
excuse me
just driving across the countryside
this guy got some yobu moves
yeah
for real
i filled my flasks up that are full
thank you bud well some of the bugs gave
us some uh some of those new moves and
stuff oh you think the bug filled up
your floss yeah yeah the big ones
remember it didn't give us anything yeah
it'll fill up your flask unless you're
already at max there he is
that's cool
all right let's see what these guys go
around them
that party did i think he said that it's
there was some
writing about
guarding of the bridge or something i
don't remember
i just remember he waited oh geez until
night fell and then the butt that guy
like faded it
was just like destiny too yeah you feel
betrayed you feel like you've been
cheated on oh he's gonna play with me
for a week
and then he's gonna like everybody else
does
get confused
how often do you play testy like when
there aren't updates um
you still do like weekly and stuff like
the challenges focus on the game
disregard everything john just said
oh
i lost sight of his weapon
you don't even know what his moveset is
when he gets off the hole all he knows
it hits me really hard oh boy
yeah that was like the last iframe yeah
i'm watching him more than the horse now
there it is
ah then i went for this wig i got greedy
i'm not sure
but i think when the horse is like
and slam
you might not have to roll if you just
get to his back feet it might not do
like an aoe
well sometimes the horse is the attacker
sometimes he's the attack oh
it's very difficult to tell which one oh
i got to choose a spot
let's just let's do the state
oh i didn't do that
there are multiplayer area limits who
are you
who's the sexy one
oh it's day night and
night night i'm kind of curious maybe
he doesn't look as cool he doesn't look
like a boss either he's not like his
biggest guy
yeah he is
i don't think that's the three sentence
it's
i wonder if there's a grace near here
because that'd be very handy
determination
i'm gonna check across the beach
i think didn't the
we came over here because of the riddle
that it left us
yeah it's across the bridge and
follow the animal trail
oh yeah
i don't know there's the convoy
yeah
i i'm not sure but i think you can just
jump on the back and get the item from
the convoy without killing those guys
oh it also said go north right
oh for the treasure yeah
yes is this the correct bridge do we
know who knows it's a bridge it's a
bridge i want to see what's up here
do some swarming
got maroons
if there's any game devs out there
we're still recording right yeah okay
there's any game devs out there please
if you do an open world
i know it's a lot more work
but please don't procedurally generate
the location of your enemies every time
you respawn
it's so much better if you choose their
placement the real same way every time
the real same way every time
gold pickled foul foot
delightful
you don't count you're not a real
developing game
just because you're professionally
employed at a game studio and you're
professionally making and developing a
game
i don't count it
program is ugly
oh my god oh that's a big whole thing
here
oh my gosh it's a parade yeah
wow oh my god so that's a little more
complicated than i initially jump on
their head
oh
i'm really bad at backseating especially
in this kind of game it's hard not to
because you're enthusiastic oh no he's
bad we don't like those ones
you'll kill him she's fault yeah she's
definitely god that's stanky yeah but
she's asleep she just needed a run uh-oh
nice
maybe it does
maybe my timing was the older shirt no
they found you that's the horn tutor
only one came to the fight
oh [ __ ] look at him
all right it just hit me yeah yeah it's
a pretty bad spot
it moves up
it was real slow hey yell at my horse
[ __ ] it yeah i think it's going to be
okay
oh they're all weak yeah
more than one horn you definitely killed
him before he finished blowing down
well there's a second one yeah two
separate parties right
well the
the caravan might have like a bunch of
horn boys
hey stop it with a torch
i'll get him
i'll get them eventually
they do have a whole space
all right they do that's all right you
took them down last time
it was really just a caravan of
skeletons
that's the cheap
i bet you this is what real-life sword
fighting is like just awkwardness
yeah yeah
horse fighting
well like forces panicking
yeah
nice i saw that recently about like
a lot of horses in medieval times were
like way smaller than we think they were
really they were like pony sized yeah
like they were just little horses with
like
nice writing on them because they have
been bred
like the ones we have today yeah
all right let's see if we can do this
they were
i mean they were being bred but they
hadn't reached the heights that we think
i do have to kill the guys
or just stop them maybe
maybe
you killed the whole party yeah yeah
that's good and i mean these guys aren't
that big
excuse me it could be fine pull over
oh [ __ ]
is he just keep going okay try now
yes
nice just have to pull him over
that's interesting
all right my work here is done
we've accomplished something we've
accomplished something we did a thing
i do want to fight that
the writer again
i just want to find like grace that's
close by oh yeah
i want to find the [ __ ] golden needle
you know we all we all have our goals
yeah
a very unproductive several hours yeah
you do different [ __ ]
it's a new way to play the game
hello eagles
all right i might head to they they
never look behind oh [ __ ]
nice nice nice nice nice nice feeling
good about it
you got the rings to level up did you
find out what that telescope looking
thing is
huh
curious go check it out let's cross the
bridge check it out
excuse me oh it is
went through dude the [ __ ] spikes
through those guys yeah is it just
nothing
that doesn't make sense maybe it's just
some kind of symbol denoting the region
maybe something in that area
oh it's that thing
oh little telescope what is that
it shows you a point of interest is a
telescope
i love what i'll do
[Music]
whoa
look for things can you mark it no you
can't
this is awesome
this is straight out of super mario
odyssey
exactly this big tree there's like a
temple over there
there's that cool guy
oh is the dragon down there oh down the
swamp
there he is there's our guy
wait wait go down
is there does that lead into oh no it
might just might be a cave
there's
there's that gate that goes in there
yeah
this is cool yeah whoa look at those
light rays gorgeous
absolutely stunning you just gotta turn
off the hood and this telescope takes
what's great all the way up there
to the right
in the middle
nope oh yeah
it's like a clip jesus
it just keeps going i know
like i was waiting to get stabbed in the
middle of my sightseeing maybe it's the
only thing that poses the game
maybe
all right i think i'm gonna try to take
on the guy again do it nightman yeah
night man
is this one closer this might be a quick
ride
i'm yawning but i'm not tired and i'll
never stop playing this game
yeah the yawns they come
the night is young
and the windows close so we can yell as
much as we want yeah i couldn't keep you
outside is it night right now well when
your alarm was going off you were
sitting right outside i was like
yeah
[Music]
nightfall
all right
you got it this time dude you got it all
right coming through
oh it's the camp remember
[Laughter]
um
some of them are so close to each other
it is confusing yeah
very strong yeah i think it's probably
high traffic areas or [ __ ] like this
where it's in front of like boss
my hands
which is just boss but smaller
boss but busy most bodies
i need that
we got any upgrade things have we
maybe just go to go to flasks and try
both of the
add charge and
oh yeah oh it costs more
yeah what about increase
stick for tear damage
i mean yeah we haven't done anything
we've just been to places
yet
um let's see what we got something else
determination or whatever
oh press uh press
x or click click your stick
i click it again
quick stick i did oh
oh it changes order
oh wait
go press x
x don't do nothing all right whatever
[Laughter]
you're welcome
oh hello
second try nice
200 souls can you get rid of my old
beacons
excuse me boys
those trees are so dang pretty it's true
i do still think sakura is really pretty
i'm digging it
dark souls 2 is the prettiest
yeah
the colors just the color palette alone
it's like that yellow green
era of video games yeah
yeah it's gorgeous
and then when they do bring color it's
like a neon green that poisons
that time it was just the horse i wonder
if you stay on his right side will be
easier to
where's the shot
yeah he really only holds it on one side
that's the biggest problem here
[Music]
see that time it was just forced
sometimes it is also man when it nays
sometimes it's man
sometimes that's what i need to do sound
cues
being uh in attendance seems to be
really helping out yeah it's oh i gotta
wait for the bridge
not fair that that works for them
i think it's when it nays
here we'll let's keep watching for when
it doesn't say we think nay is the only
host yeah nay is just horse stone okay
this is going well
i hate this move
does he ever hit you with it though
i think you're right about this yeah
going on our right okay swing again
you're right i do forget that we're
recording
[Laughter]
we've been going for
four now
oh guys
he hasn't done like the swing and
the rear
again since we started noticing
oh god we killed somebody we killed a
boss
where's my prize
actually
i am an expert so yeah before you even
elbowed me before you even elbowed me
about it
good job jacob yeah that was amazing
that was a that was a good one all right
where are we going no it's up to you
it's your hour do what you want
do whatever you want um
[ __ ] it i'll go back i want my revenge
was that here
yeah that's it okay let's give it a shot
let's see how it goes
can you pause me and click
yeah
you can answer
castorona
all right barbara what
so what you
our name is
portal corporal martha's been waiting
for so long
where did you go oh yeah
what have you been
well we don't doing that much more
damage yeah but you know but but think
about all the skills
yeah i want to figure out how to farm
shirts
yeah
so we can upgrade our
you think george rr martin did all the
localization for sure yeah
here are you get away from that cliff
edge
i just touched the cod
i wonder if the localization worked with
backless
well george i thought george r martin
just gave ideas
like helped with the
i don't want to be in that corner
and see rolls yeah
i feel like you are doing better
than previously
i do love wolves
oh my wolves
[Laughter]
oh no no no no no
it landed and then coughed up ghost
blood yeah bore
all right
you got it dude you got it i was gonna
be more cautious
when he gets in that crazy phasey
he's a big angry bully yes you have
three minutes well
as much time as you want
oh we're opening with the [ __ ] huh
oh
[ __ ]
oh yeah
we haven't got any homework oh you have
a sword at the beginning huh
i need to hit him once
oh my god you haven't hit him oh my god
okay
oh you little [ __ ] the the rng man
sometimes it's like yeah for sure oh
oh there we go now i'm on the board it's
rng
like it chooses a different i mean it
would still be rng
but that like it could be that the ai is
triggered
i've always wondered if like
i mean i'm sure it's different but if
it's like
move by move or if
when you enter the arena sometimes it's
like he's gonna be super aggro
or he's gonna be more cautious he'll
have a sword this time yeah exactly
you're right that i think the sword is
probably rng i would think the behavior
is always insane i think we've only seen
the sword one time at this stage the
fight yeah
oh hammer huh there's definitely some
boss fights for you ai manipulation
but
not
give me all
more
nice
sword
yeah let's get rushed me with the stick
oh it's double it's so funny that he
yeah oh
bad time for a heel
whatever [ __ ] it [ __ ] it [ __ ] it [ __ ]
i'll let them do their work this time
there fight them yeah bite them up
oh
it oh yeah get a wolf you're my last
hope
how much a wolf oh
no oh
do we have 5 000 souls yeah yeah we have
a lot
because we killed the yeah
now we have to
what could we maybe
we don't have any homework
whatever the equivalent
i don't even think is seen it
you're right
do your sword [ __ ]
or there's a double double swing yep oh
i keep feeling how like odd my face is
tensing watching this
this yeah a good even just a block
you're dead yeah
come on
you'll be fine
oh no
no one at all can't survive those things
oh i'm just taking the pokes where i can
get them yeah i don't want to gamble
dodge
block the first one dodge the hammer
your butt
it's not good it's not good
okay
i think my theory is right that
technically you
he does attacks
hold on
no no oh
that's that's [ __ ] sword he did sword
do the next hour that's what i say
oh
my heart is pounding okay
that's this is the same thing that
happened last time got into that rhythm
with him but this time i'm not going to
waste all my flasks
sorry i was just
i was like oh i have 5 000 souls i don't
you do not he does yeah
well now i forget how this phase works
wait where are the souls
all right thank you for waiting margaret
appreciate it
okay
so yeah i think it's not being involved
with this whole thing at all yeah
i think that's what we learned last time
was yeah sorted out
bit uh back in yeah
yeah that's what we said sort out back
[Laughter]
there's the rush and now we know oh [ __ ]
no
no with the sword
bad boy
baby boy it's because
i don't know
i i haven't seen him do that where he
just
swings out yeah
but before that he did a swing that
didn't look like the other
because it wasn't the charge of one
it wasn't that one
yeah
it was like from the left shoulder
down
i can't hold it scratching my face
i'll let you know yeah you scratched
yourself you're tickling me
when he does the double knife throw and
then attack it's actually very fun
we'll have the hammer the walls stand by
yes
that's how [ __ ] confident you are you
know what's on standby instead of
mosques
you live like this you also have those
electro grenades yeah
ah [ __ ]
he's done it like
twice
no
no no maybe he does
both swords back to back
that's what happened last time yeah
he hit the orbs before they
not really before they shot yeah
remember there's another spell that was
like that where they didn't look very
powerful
oh
remember no they're like kind of cute
yeah
but after the orbs go up they then shoot
out
something [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm just uh i'm out of here that's good
sold out
[Applause]
where are you going
there you go do you serve on that kill
i'll kill my wolves
okay seated on the walls
wolf's still good that's a good wolf
that's for me
nice
oh for the wolf
all right
i have more health than i did last time
at this point which is more than zero
right correct
all right so when he does the magic
stuff like the knives it still does chip
damage yeah a little bit
and a second swing
no i i left and said i was going to wear
shorts and then
i'm just attacking all my attacks at a
very specific time
oh
that's unusual
yeah he went straight into the uh yeah
he didn't throw both this one
oh you [ __ ]
you didn't really scratch take it i did
no scratch i should have asked
okay here we go
you don't see me anti-ice cream um okay
oh again again
oh [ __ ]
i did blender a lot in that one too
summoning the wolves while he was
running up to me yeah it's okay it's
okay
we learn every day
that we do
all right margaret
smarter every day
i said hey what kind of leg
nice oh
[Laughter]
first
oh you little [ __ ]
i wonder if you could cheat it
if you stand directly against the fog
wall
and then die you can then pick up your
bicycle yeah
try
that's a pretty fun idea
all right do your stupid throwing knife
[ __ ]
maybe i will
or maybe you die
he already does the devil
or does he always i think he always has
oh he missed me he did miss you
margaret making mistakes
yeah i'm not the only one getting sloppy
today
for three swings
dude how would you
how did you program this
without or
how do you design this these fights
without the models
because usually you just use you know
they just place those
would it just be a skeleton that's sort
of
i have no idea yeah
um
yeah because in platformers and stuff
you just use squares and circles
yeah
um
yes
yes
[Music]
sorry man
buddy
there's so many blood stains here i know
they're all mine
damn chip damage
okay right into the giant hop
should i take my flask right now yeah
oh
oh no oh it's not that bad i couldn't
wait
just do that over and over yeah more of
that one
do it i dare you oh [ __ ]
i think also when he does the swipe
hammer if you roll forward instead of
back
like that
there's always risk of the sword yeah
yeah you're right being too close in
general this is bad it's a shame that
you have to be to hit him yeah
running out of real estate here
oh
oh you little [ __ ]
do that
next time next
come on
[Music]
my best moment there for attack
i would definitely be too aggressive on
this
oh no that's good not good at all
you got this he does seem very hard for
such an early boss or are we just super
on the left
i mean we could do it
yeah
[ __ ]
oh
right through my shield okay whatever
oh all right i think before we stop
just go in and stand against the door
and get killed okay well i guess you
gotta grab your souls first your
dreams i gotta get my rooms we're back
to the door
all right good plan good plan feels
unlikely but we'll try yeah
but you remember you have to be standing
there for a while for them to be there
yeah okay
so let's uh
you could just do that just run at
it it's going great
oh i was so close to that one
oh my gosh he was one hit away as one
hit away
look we're coming for you margaret we'll
get you one of these videos
is that your goal for this next hour get
market get market yeah you can hit stop
on that one probably well no no let's
see if the runes
there's no way it'll it'll be on the
numpad
we tried
all right
sometimes
sometimes you don't get the souls